Welcome back witches it's Charlie this is going
to be my video for the other Wandavision sequel
series The Agatha Harkness coven of chaos
episodes they just announced a bunch more
of the cast the details and people who are coming
back from the Wandavision Series along with other
major MCU characters we also learned about some
of the other cool connections that it has with
the other upcoming Marvel movies The Other
series and obviously Elizabeth Olsen Scarlet
witch coming back for this as well it also seems
like we learned about an adult version of Billy
whose coming back as full-blown Wiccan during
the series like we've seen the young version
of the character during Wandavision and Doctor
Strange 2 but now it seems like we're going to
see the adult version of the character finally
show up I literally just did another Wandavision
sequel video that's going to be all about what
happens to White Vision that's a completely
different series I'll post a link to that
video at the end of this and down in the
description below if you're new to the channel
I'll be doing episode videos for all these when
they start be sure to subscribe to get them the
Agatha Harkness coven of chaos series is going
to Premiere first though the white Vision series
Vision Quest isn't going to come till after that
the reason why we learn earned all this coven
of chaos Wandavision sequel stuff is because
they're literally starting to shoot right now
but the biggest news is that Elizabeth Olsen
and Aubrey Plaza are going to be on the series
obviously Elizabeth Olsen playing Scarlet Witch
Aubrey Plaza is supposed to be playing one of
the villains during the series hearing this I
know everybody's going to ask is she still playing
the Shadow King is she going to be a version of
her character from the legion X-Men series that
would actually be amazing everything is connected
thank you
we also learned about a cool connection with
the iron heart series and Anthony Ramos's Hood
character Mephisto yes I actually said Mephisto
supposedly played by Sasha Baron Cohen nolas they
also announced a bunch of lesser characters that
are going to be on the coven of chaos series but
I'm going to talk more about the bigger characters
during this video obviously it's meant to be a
direct sequel to the events of Wandavision just
like the white Vision show and they've changed
the title to coven of chaos which tells you a
lot about what the show is actually about like
it's Agatha the Harkness of the show but she's
basically building a Coven in present day in the
MCU in the chaos in the title is a reference to
Scarlet Witch's chaos magic as in her coming back
to the series if you're not a huge fan of witches
or witch base magic lore covens are just what you
call groups of witches Who band together during
the wandavision episodes in the flashbacks to
her origin story you see she was alive during the
Salem Witch Trials era hundreds of years ago in
her own coven led by her mother turned against her
when they found out that she'd been dabbling in
Forbidden dark magic and using the dark old more
on that in a second because it think what she was
doing with the dark hold isn't totally over even
though Scarlet Witch destroyed the darkhold temple
that cathome built during Doctor Strange 2 which
destroyed all the copies of the darkhold book by
default and that was meant to be across the entire
Multiverse like there was one dark hold Temple
that all the dark hole books across the Multiverse
had been copied from Once you destroy the temple
it automatically destroyed all the books but the
show is meant to explain what Agatha Harkness does
after she breaks Scarlet Witch's chaos magic
spell she put on her trapping her in that fake
life is Dottie the wife of Ralph boner so make all
your Evan Peters Quicksilver jokes I know there's
still a ton of questions about what was going on
with Ralph boner Quicksilver but at the end of one
division Scarlet Witch trapped her in that life
with her chaos magic and basically the same thing
that happened to Odin in Thor Ragnarok happened to
AGA the Harkness like Loki made Odin forget who he
was using his magic for a little while until Odin
was able to break his magic after the Harkness did
the same thing she's a very powerful witch in
the MCU it just took her a little while longer
to break the chaos magic spell since then in the
the background like while we've been watching all
these Marvel movies during phase four she's
slowly been building her power base back up
pulling strings influencing other lesser magic
users in the MCU they're doing the same thing
with her that they do with a character like Namor
and black panther 2 presenting them as more of an
anti-hero not like a straight up villain and
they kind of did that during one division two
like she wanted her chaos magic but there was also
things that Scarlet Witch was doing that were more
dangerous that Agatha Harkness was worried
about you have no idea what you've unleashed
you're gonna need me here's when we get to the
connection to Iron Heart Doctor Doom and other
big magic users inside the MCU that they're slowly
setting up it's all about the Battle of Magic
versus technology because that's what they're
doing in the iron Hard series that's why Anthony
Ramos's character is in the series because he's
a magic user but he also uses guns and why would
you use guns if you're a magic user the whole
idea is he's supposed to be working for Agatha
Harkness during that series and you talk about the
Battle of Magic versus technology that's basically
core Doctor Doom he's a man of science and a man
of magic like what is the relationship between
Magic and Technology that's just more than slowly
setting up Doctor Doom in the background when he
eventually does show up in some Future movie
AG the Harkness might have a cameo during the
ironheart series just to reference her connection
to the Anthony Ramos Hood character but that's
also supposedly where Mephisto is going to show
up for the first time played by Sasha Baron Cohen
the events of coven of chaos episodes are them
just dealing with Agatha harkness's new master
plan and setting up larger Magic based villains
and characters in the MCU it's a lot of the same
energy energy is the doctor strange movies which
is more of a supernatural Bend like they just
kind of started to tease that during the first
Doctor Strange movie in Doctor Strange Multiverse
of Badness like there's a lot of other Magic
based villains out there in the Multiverse that
are slowly closing in on planet Earth and even
though we've been making all the Mephisto jokes
and there's all these rumors about Sasha Baron
Cohen the bigger Magic based villain is c'thon
the god of chaos the person who gave Scarlet Witch
her chaos magic powers in Aubrey Plaza is supposed
to be playing one of the main villains during
coven of chaos now keep in mind during that series
they're playing out of the Harkness like she's
more of an anti-hero so if Aubrey Plaza is playing
the villain she'd have to be somebody who's way
worse yes it is totally possible that she could
just be playing her character from the legion
series she was a version of Lenny Busker but then
secretly basically was playing a version of The
Shadow King controlling Lenny Busker so most of
her time on the series was actually her playing a
version of The Shadow King it'd just be amazing if
they just brought that character to coven of Chaos
in the MCU they've already brought Patrick Stewart
back as a version of Professor X from the X-Men
animated series they're also bringing Deadpool
and Hugh Jackman's Wolverine from the X-Men movies
as well and Deadpool 3. if she's playing a totally
new character somebody completely different
there are only a couple human-based villainous
magic user characters like Morgan le fay if they
just decide to change that a little bit she'd be
the top pick because virtually all the other human
level female witches female magic users are either
good characters like fundamentally good like X-Men
characters or runaways like Nico who isn't an evil
character so they wouldn't be villains during
this coven of chaos series but she also might
just be playing a straight up demon or god they're
a couple big gods in the MCU that are connected to
what happened during one division Doctor Strange
2 in a connection to the more Magic based darker
characters like Agatha harkness' character for
instance chthon the god of chaos that's where
all the dark hole Temple plot during Multiverse
of Madness comes from in Doctor Strange too they
barely touched on that like I said I think they
were just kind of setting things up that they
would deal with in a future Scarlet Witch Solo
movie there's also the Lilith character mother
of demons she started as a human who fell to
Darkness succumbed to Satan's influence and became
his bride in ancient times and ever since then has
just been doing a lot of large-scale demonic stuff
in the MCU mostly connected to the ghost writer
mythology there's also a lady death like the
cosmic concept of death which they teased during
Thor love and thunder it just depends on how big
you think of a character Aubrey Plaza is playing
like is she going to be playing a demon a God or
just like another character that they pull out of
Marvel Comics most of you've probably seen some of
her other Marvel related stuff like she was on the
legion TV show she's played a lot of other demonic
characters so this is something that she really
enjoys doing like her own personality she really
enjoys witches witch-based culture Halloween just
in general so sort of like a dream come true for
her that she was cast in this MCU Agatha Harkness
show Elizabeth Olsen coming back as Scarlet which
is fairly self-explanatory I've already talked
about that during my white Vision Video a couple
of days ago like she didn't die at the end of
Doctor Strange to her chaos magic powers protected
her the bigger thing I think is the idea that they
might might be doing an older version of Billy or
a Wiccan played by Joe Locke from heartstopper
in the comics Billy and Tommy's actual backstory
is super trippy in what they've done with the
characters in one division Doctor Strange 2 kind
of lean into that like she created them using
her chaos magic but then she took them away
with her chaos magic they weren't quite like the
other hex Creations but they're also Multiverse
versions of the characters the whole idea is in
Doctor Strange too is that in the 838 universe
there were versions of Billy and Tommy that that
Scarlet Witch or that Wanda hadn't gotten rid of
by dissolving with her chaos magic like 838 Wanda
had just kept them around permanently and in the
MCU as we've seen during one division Billy's
powers are basically the exact same as Scarlet
witches which is a couple minor twists like the
energy given off by his powers have a blue energy
not a red energy but he can warp reality just like
she can he's also a mutant he has Clairvoyance
telekinesis pretty much anything that Scarlet
Witch can do the funny thing about Billy in the
comics though is they never exactly explained
where his powers actually come from because of
his unique backstory in the comics which is a
little bit different than the MCU backstory I
think they'll just simplify that in the MCU and
just say oh he just got his powers biologically
from her like she just passed them on to him and
it's a result of her chaos magic abilities because
of what they've done with the character in the
MCU so far like we've seen Multiverse versions
but r616 Wanda basically got rid of her versions
of Billy and Tommy with her chaos magic the adult
version that we eventually see possibly during
coven of chaos if that's who Joe Locke is playing
could just be another Multiverse version or from a
different plane of existence and because Elizabeth
Olsen said that she wanted to do more X-Men movie
crossovers now that they had the X-Men back in the
Marvel Universe Scarlet Witch solo movies I also
think one of the movies that coven of chaos helps
set up because all the Disney plus series are
meant to set up future movies will be the next
big Scarlet Witch movie where they cover a lot of
her chaos magic backstory and what's going on with
chthon the god of chaos like remember that weird
plan that we had in Doctor Strange 2 like why did
he create the dark hole Temple what did he want
Scarlet Witch to do with her chaos magic why was
he trying to use her to conquer the Multiverse
there's just a lot of open plot threads that
they set up during that movie Never Fully answered
because like I said they plan on answering those
in other future movies and series but the basic
idea is the chthon the god of chaos was trying to
use Scarlet Witch as a back door to conquer the
Multiverse like he wanted to use her power in
the dark hole Temple to conquer the Multiverse and
then he basically turned her into a finger puppet
and Rule through her one of the big things with a
darkhold book is that they're basically consumed
by the book driven mad or they're taken over by
kathon like he'll take over their minds if we have
any luck too we'll get multiple seasons of the
show but if you have any other big questions about
what's going on with the agatha harkness coven of
chaos series just write them in the comments below
and I'll do more videos as we get more footage
trailers and learn more about the characters
everyone click here to learn about the other one
division sequel the white Vision series and click
here for my new Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania
trailer video with a whole bunch of Kang the
Conqueror thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!